nine people lost their lives in a
terrible accident on saturday in bng standards it
is due to a
speeding driver such
health to cristian casseres this happened
on giant avenue near commercial street
a driver was driving more than 100
miles per  time when he ran a
red light and collided with another vehicle a
total of six cars and 15 people
were involved in this
accident for more details visit
our snow dotcom page in the
spanish section
expert from the southern nevada health district
says this car  mccann the sub-
variant of the virus was already detected here
in the county court the doctors said
that she is a woman in her 40s who
recently traveled outside the country and already
has three doses of the vaccine
and is in recovery at the
moment no  there is evidence that this
variant is more severe than the previous ones
and there is new news from
las vegas values the team prepares to annou
ce  formally announce the arrival of a
new general manager and a new
coach both come from the
patriots level when the saints will be the new
leader while josh
mcdaniels coach and we close with a look
at temperatures we can enjoy a few
nice days with temperatures in the 60s
degrees the winds will return on
Wednesday causing a drop in
temperatures for the nights it will be a
little colder around 36 degrees
I'm Cristian Cáceres with about the
Spanish inclusion news good
day
[Music]